les banques ont-elles une responsabilité
dans l'un des plus grands fléaux de la
planète la pollution plastique
oui à en croire un rapport de portfolio
of l'organisation révèle que les plus
grandes banques internationales ont
financé le secteur du plastique à
hauteur de 1700 milliards de dollars
depuis 2015 soit 800 millions de dollars
par jour dans le trio de tête figurent
bank of america citigroup jpmorgan
chez les français on retrouve bnp
paribas avec 56 milliards de dollars de
financements ou encore la société
générale avec 38 milliards et parmi les
entreprises qui profitent le plus de
cette manne
basf dahouche amical exxon coca cola et
pepsico danone mars ou encore unilever
amazon par leur financement sans
discernement des acteurs de la filière
plastique
les banques ont failli à leur mission en
favorisant la pollution mondiale par le
plastique ils sont nettement à la traîne
d'autres acteurs impliqués dans cette
crise de la pollution au plastique et
pour avoir une idée de ce que représente
la pollution plastique et ses dangers
ces quelques chiffres il faut savoir
d'abord avec un tiers des déchets
plastiques soit 100 millions de tonnes
se retrouvent chaque année dans la
nature au lui en terre rivière et océans
1,5 millions d'animaux sont tués tous
les ans piégées et tout fait empoisonné
par ses déchets et des experts prévoient
même qu'en 2050 il y aura plus de
plastique que de poissons dans la mer
350 millions de tonnes c'est le niveau
que pourrait atteindre d'ici à 2030 les
émissions de dioxyde de carbone
résultant de l'incinération ou du
déversement à ciel ouvert de déchets
plastiques
à l'instar du charbon et des énergies
fossiles est les experts alertent sur
les dangers du plastique et appelle les
banques à prendre leurs responsabilités
malgré le tollé général suscité par les
impacts graves de la pollution par les
plastiques et malgré les efforts de
certaines entreprises du secteur du
plastique
pour réduire leur empreinte aucune des
banques analysées n'a développé de
systèmes de vérification de critères de
prêt conditionnel ou d'exclusion de
financement à l'égard de cette industrie
cela veut dire que les banques n'assume
pas de prendre la responsabilité de
comprendre mesurer et réduire l'impact
de leur financement de la filière
plastique
le problème c'est que le coût de la
pollution au plastique n'est pas assumée
par les acteurs qui tire profit de sa
production
comprenez il est moins coûteux de
rejeter les déchets directement dans la
nature que de gérer leur fin de vie
signe de l'ampleur du phénomène un
septième continent fait de plastique a
commencé à se former il ya une vingtaine
d'années il occupe 1,6 million de
kilomètres carrés dans l'océan pacifique
entre hawaï et la californie ils
concentrent 80 mille tonnes de déchets
et il n'est pas près de disparaître
puisque le plastique mais entre 500 et
1000 ans à se dégrader alors question si
les banques ne font rien et aggrave même
la situation comment changer les choses
un autre horizon est possible celui
d'une nature sans plastique cela passe
notamment par la réduction de 28% de la
production de plastique par rapport à
l'élimination progressive du plastique à
usage unique
la collecte de sang pour sang de nos
déchets et le recyclage de 60 % des
déchets collectés pour y parvenir
des solutions existent déjà et doivent
être renforcés telles que l'interdiction
du plastique à usage unique
problématique le soutien au réemploi
l'élimination des additifs toxiques qui
freine le recyclage ou encore la
recherche d'alternatives durable
conscient du problème une soixantaine de
pays l'an pris à bras le corps en
bannissant notamment la production de
sacs de paille et autres gobelets en
plastique
cela ne suffit peut-être pas mais c'est
déjà ça